welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
with sean stevenson
sean stevenson is an author and
nutritionist
he was great super entertaining he wrote
the best-selling books
sleep smarter and eat smarter sean was
able to overcome and
absolutely debilitating degenerative
disc disease as a young adult through
diet research and lifestyle choices
check out his most recent book please
remember to hit subscribe if you'd like
to see more and to check out my clips
channel
if you want clips i'd like to
reintroduce you to one of my favorite
snacks
brooklyn bildong available at
brooklynbiltong.com
one of the easiest ways to get healthy
the laziest ways
is to replace the over processed food
and snacks
that are no good that you're eating with
healthy food that's still kind of snacky
i went cold turkey into pure health food
no packaged foods no fun
i didn't know how to cook i was 23. it
was really not great
and honestly a huge part of that was
because there weren't any packaged foods
that were healthy enough that i could
comfortably eat
with my insanely limited autoimmune
paleo diet at that time
brooklyn biltong is a small company that
makes biltong which is a south african
dried
meat dish and their options are either
spiced or made with just salt and apple
cider vinegar their naked version which
is what i eat
and beef code mp for 15 off if you're
constantly snacking
seriously consider switching to
something like this it's a health food
packaged up like something unhealthy
that's brooklynbiltong.com and use
codemp for 15
off they're also linked below i'd show
you guys the product
but i'm away from the lockdown haven
that is ontario
and i also ate it all please enjoy this
[Music]
episode
[Music]
sean stevenson welcome to my podcast
thank you so much for having me i'm
excited so
mai can you start off by giving us a
brief background about who you are and
what it is that you do
sure absolutely so i'm a nutritionist
and author of the international
best-selling book sleep smarter
in my newest book eat smarter and i've
been in this field for
19 years now and of course the people
seeing on the video they're like hey
you're a baby
but i actually have a 20 year old son
and a nine-year-old son who both in the
house right now it's you know
the quarantine situation here in la
still so
i've you know been in this field for a
very long time and
working with thousands of patients over
the years but also just
primarily working as a research
scientist and just really staying on top
of the data
and helping to educate the public you
know and taking very complex
because a lot of folks don't realize
this that you know once we get a
double-blind placebo-controlled trial
proving the effectiveness of
let's just say curcumin right which is a
bioactive in turmeric
which it's known now that it has
anti-angiogenesis genesis properties so
that means it can literally help to cut
off the
blood supply to cancer cells right so
once we have this
confirmation double-blind
placebo-controlled trial gold standard
the time it takes from proof to getting
into clinical practice takes an average
of 17
years which is insane it's absolutely
crazy
and a big part of this is just public
education because
a lot of these studies are done by you
know just in the language
of academia and it's read through the
lens of academia
instead of being practical for people
who can use it right now
so i've just taken these complex
unnecessarily complex data and making it
understandable for everyday folks to
take advantage of things that
i believe everybody should know about so
but
you know just being in this field for
this amount of time you know i've seen a
lot of different trends i've seen a lot
of different
uh incredible occurrences and i've also
seen a lot of tragedy
as well you know and i think it's kind
of a well-rounded perspective to have
right now
and you know i really got into this
field initially
and we're going to talk about this later
i'm sure but i initially got in this
field
um i i thought it was a good idea to go
to medical school right just because of
what i saw on television
not because i like science at all
because i actually hated science i
hated it and i would have this recurring
nightmare this is a true story
of this biology class in high school and
i had this dream so many times it's just
like
not having my homework done you know
dissecting things and just is very
uncomfortable and the teacher she just
had this vibe of just like
just kind of wicked you know um but
anyway so i went to school just on the
premise of seeing on television like it
looks like a good career i
i never met let alone um known anybody
not just to go to college but to
graduate from college
from where i come from i'm from ferguson
missouri and you know in st
louis missouri and um but of course like
my professors
you know i'm sure that they graduated
that kind of thing but just anybody in
my peer group or my family
and but again like i said i really
detested science
and fortunately i was i went to a
private university with a good pre-med
track
but i saw there was this really strange
obsession with my
uh fellow students with just pathology
self-diagnosis
and fear right we start to learn about
diseases and all of a sudden like you
think you've got everything
right and you started yeah okay you know
what i mean you know so it started to
really freak me out early on
and also i took my first nutritional
science class which was totally elective
this had nothing to do with the pre-med
track i took it because i thought
nutrition was about fitness and the
teacher was going to teach me to be more
fit
it was this big auditorium classroom and
the very first day and this is
again true story my teacher came in and
he was
bordering on obesity and he was a
incredibly intelligent guy like man he
was super smart
but he was a victim of this system which
is really miseducating people and he was
doing the things that he was teaching
but it wasn't working for him
and he didn't have the wherewithal to
acknowledge like hey this food pyramid
the 7-eleven servings of grains
low-fat this whole diet framework we
were taught
is not working for me i need to change
instead we just do it harder like i just
need to cut more fat
i just need 14 to 20 servies of whole
grains you know
and so i became very disenchanted
with it and it was very unconscious
though so i got out of
my medic my medicine track belief
fortunately and then i shifted over at
the school they also had a good mba
program
so i got into business for a while but
then i had my own health issue
which is a whole story of itself but you
know i was diagnosed with a so-called
incurable spinal condition
and what was that degenerative disc
disease
yeah that's not good there's advanced
arthritis in my spine
and the physician the very first one
that i saw told me that i had the spine
of an eight-year-old man when i was just
20.
and i was an aspiring athlete like when
i was in high school i ran a 4
5 40 which is nfl time when i was 15
years old
and i went to one of those high schools
that just churns out professional
athletes
but i have game films you know like i've
showed my son recently
of me breaking away on a touchdown like
running a 39 sweep and
i'm away from the defensive backs and i
just collapse just
nobody touches me i just collapsed
because of an injury and
i broke my hip at track practice just
running nobody touched me
and this was really a side effect of my
body being
made of absolute the worst possible
things imaginable i was making my
tissues out of these things which i
didn't know till later so but long story
short with this
uh getting that diagnosis it also
elicited what's known as a nocebo effect
right so it's the opposite of a placebo
which most folks don't realize again in
clinical studies
placebos are about 33 effective on
average
right so this is just the belief that
this pill is going to normalize your
blood sugar or
even start to break down a cancer tumor
or reduce your symptoms of depression
the list goes on and on
about 33 effective on average a nacibo
effect is the opposite where you get a
negative injunction
you know you'll never walk again this is
incurable you've got six weeks to
live and these are some of the things
that patients that i've worked with over
the years would hear and also i heard
which was
this is incurable you'll never be able
to live a normal life
and i was relented to be on you know
plethora of drugs
chronic pain but about two years after
that diagnosis
is when i finally had a shift in my
belief system which ultimately all
change comes from that
and i just decided to get well which i
had never thought about before you know
because i
believe that i couldn't get well and i
just began to study everything that i
detested earlier on
i began to study biology again and
kinesiology
and anatomy and nutrition and what i
really learned and this is my last point
is that
our system of health and our perspective
about health is not about health
it's just a focus on disease and disease
treatment
and so i immerse myself in all things
that
my genes expect me to have as a healthy
sovereign human being
you know and just began to immerse my my
my mind and my body in those things and
you know i completely reversed the
degeneration my two herniated discs had
retracted on their own
and that set might set on track my
career you know to become a nutritionist
and work with patients and
write books and now i'm here with you
today
damn okay um i have a i don't know how
much
my background you know but uh i was
diagnosed with juvenile
rheumatoid arthritis when i was little
and i had my hip and ankle replaced
so where we're coming from
i hope that face shows up in the podcast
holy moly is right
so um i get the fear associated with
degenerating bones
uh what were you just out of curiosity
what were you put on when they
discovered you had arthritis yeah
so and this is even that you know what
it can really look like if people want
to frame it when we're talking about
degeneration of really any part of the
body specifically of the spine in the
disc
you know so i did bone degeneration my
bone density was incredibly low
which you would think just to ask like
okay why is the bone density so low for
a kid
and let's do something about it but it
was more so oh this is a random thing
i'm sorry this happened to you but i was
put on
man everything from i really started off
light with like celebrex
and the big thing for me though
was sleeping at night and so i was on
medication to sleep because just even
moving around pain wow adding nerve pain
so sometimes i would sleep for like 30
minutes and then
be woken up and then sleep another 20
minutes and be woken up it was an
absolute nightmare
you know like i guess it's a pun uh
intended
or not intended but it was a nightmare
for those two years
and so but seller here's oh this is what
i wanted to tell you
came come to find out celebrex one of
the side effects
of celebrex was restless leg syndrome oh
my god i had that
that is horrible
it's crazy right so it's just like i
didn't but it didn't have a name yet
it didn't have a name for this but now
we've got restless legs so now we've got
another drug for that
instead of like let's remove the thing
that's causing the restless legs which
for me was the celebrex
and so i was laying in bed not only was
i like knocking myself out with with the
drug in the first place but it felt
like my legs was trying to just get up
and go i'm just like you know it's the
craziest
uh situation and this is again this
paradigm
of treating symptoms and then we have
this label of what are called these
quote side effects
but that's looking at the human body in
a vacuum right so i'm taking a
medication for my bones
that's not gonna affect your your heart
i'm taking a medication
for my you know my gastrointestinal
tract that's not gonna affect your brain
it affects everything if you're taking a
medication
for you know for your vision it's going
to affect your toes
everything is interconnected it's not
side effects it's direct effects because
everything
really works together yes
i hear that i had a whole bunch of them
that i didn't realize were side effects
i thought that they were part of the
autoimmune disorder i had
and i didn't realize there were side
effects like came off the medication
until people started
i started doing research and was like
are you kidding me
that was very uncomfortable at the time
like good to know now
but i mean at least at least you know
now uh
okay so let me see where do i want to
start with with that
so what did you you started to do
research
and you were primarily motivated because
you were
ill and on a whole bunch of medication
actually let's start let's start with
your mindset
because people underestimate especially
sick people like
they underestimate the effect mindset
can have so what changed and how did you
manage to change your mindset
into i'm going to heal yeah this is so
important
you know i always tell people every
chance i get that there's many paths to
the goal
you know and for different people
there's going to be a different inroads
to health and what it looks like
and for me you know the first the first
big
transformation was and some people get
this some people never get it some
people it just takes a little bit of
time
it took me two years from that moment of
diagnosis
and just imminent decline and i went in
with the nuisance of a pain like i was
having some leg pain
to chronic debilitating pain right and
i always encourage people to make sure
to get a second hand or third opinion
before you take
any kind of severe action with your
health you have time
99.9 of the time you have time to get a
second opinion but the
the system of medicine again it's very
aggressive
it's very like put their elbow into you
force you to make a decision
you need to seek out further counsel and
so
fortunate and i didn't know this at the
time i just happened to do it because
you know i was this is another thing
that that my first physician told me he
said that
um you know this is something that just
happens because i asked him and i have
no idea to this day why i asked this
question but i asked him
does this have anything to do with what
i'm eating and i truly feel it was like
one of those
i don't know back to future moments like
i kind of jumped into my body from
from the future or something and asked
this question i had no grounds to ask
and he told he literally looked at me
like i was from another planet he said
this has nothing to do with what you're
eating
this is something that just happens and
i'm sorry it happened to you
um and from there going to the next
position
same story you know i'm sorry this
happened
here's a new prescription also here's
another
uh note for bed rest so you for your
teachers
for yours for your work but the craziest
part is
i could walk still i could move around
but they kept giving me a permission
slip to not do anything as a matter of
fact if i do something i'm risking my
life
i'm risking my health then a third
physician and finally it was a fourth
physician and
you know it'd be like a friend of mine
would say hey this guy's the best
and the best still told me the same
thing which is this is incurable i'm
sorry
and after that fourth position that was
two years later it was either that night
or the next night
i was sitting on the edge of my bed
about to take my pills
and i realized and
i'm just sharing i don't share this very
often but i had the thought of him
having dinner with his family you know
this physician
and just his life is okay and i just had
this feeling like he's not thinking
about me
and i'm so obsessed i was chronically
asking this question in my mind it was
on repeat
why me why won't somebody help me you
know and
i talk about this in each smarter this
there's this it's a mental reflex it's
called instinctive elaboration
and the human mind really is chronically
just constantly running on questions
it drives our attention and our focus
but albeit it's usually
unconscious and so i'm asking why me
why is this happening to me why won't
somebody help me and i'm getting further
data that i'm looking for in my internal
external environment to affirm why
me why my life sucks why nobody can help
me
yeah yeah and i finally asked that night
when i realized like man
even though he means means well he's not
thinking about me as i'm over here
suffering
i have to live in this and this is the
first time i asked this question it's
very simple
i asked what can i do to get better what
can i do
to get better and again i i'd relented
to give my
health potential away to somebody else
even if they meant well he didn't walk
in my shoes
and so that night and this is again true
story
i slept through the night for the first
time in like
in in my recent memory at the time and i
got up the next day and i put a plan
together
and the planet entailed a couple of
things one the low-hanging fruit which
is always
what i recommend for folks but for me it
was movement and exercise
being an athlete being somebody who was
kind of versed in that sphere
i just wanted to start moving around
again because i gained like 40 pounds at
this point
and i knew i want i needed to change my
nutrition because but for my mindset and
this is very important we'll talk about
today
i believe that just getting some of the
weight off my body
would take weight off of my spine right
this wasn't about
health per se it was just like a kind of
logical
thing and to do that
i went back to what i learned in my
nutritional science class from the guy
who was already not very healthy
which was caloric management the very
first day of class he told me
and he told the entire class and
everybody in our society has been
inundated with this idea
if you can control calories you can
control your body composition
if you can control and manage calories
you can manage your health
and so i just went on like this caloric
restriction thing
doing like slim fast and what whatever
just i didn't have any education in it
and the other part was which happened as
a side effect i started to sleep better
and if you're not sleeping you're not
healing and
you know now today what i've really
brought forth with each smarter is
there's
in this this is a term i just want
everybody to start using there are seven
epic caloric controllers so these are
things that are above caloric control
that actually determine what your body
does with the calories you consume
all right it's like epigenetics above
genetic control
and so little did i know i was kind of
activating some of these epicalor
controllers once
i made a shift which was you know asking
how can i get better i started to see
all the resources that was that were
there the whole time
i had a friend of mine who i'd known her
for years who
was a chiropractor and she took me to
wild oats which before they were bought
up by whole foods
this place had been in existence this
whole time i just was
wasn't attuned to it because i didn't
know that i could get better
and then i came across books and of
course i was already
a researcher kind of like a
pre-researcher at the time
and so i went to these books and i was
like there's a randomized controlled
trial
on um silica and omega-3s i need
omega-3s for my bone density
i never heard that i thought that it was
just calcium you know
and so once i learned this i started to
first i became a natural pill popper
i'll just be honest
i was like very allopathic thinking i
need this nutrient let me take this pill
take this pill first of all that was
expensive as hell
for being a college student second of
all you know
i'm grateful it really hit me like what
if my what do my genes expect of me
my genes expect me to eat food it's what
we evolved having
so what foods have these things in and
once i did that again i started to
elicit these epic caloric controllers i
lost like
almost 20 pounds uh within two months
and just kind of came flew right off of
me which is the result's not typical
by the way um but that mindset shift and
this is the last point
it wasn't the food here's here's the
point
food isn't just food it's information
all right food isn't just food it's
information
and so i was bringing new data into my
body and it didn't just change my body
it changed the way i was thinking like i
started to really
see the world differently at this time i
was living in ferguson missouri which is
famous or infamous at this point um
in a one one-bedroom apartment my
mattress is on the floor
my environment just screamed with
oppression and
and poor health everywhere that you look
and now all of a sudden i start to see
opportunity
i start to realize even if i have to
travel outside of my community
like to go to wildos which was miles and
miles on the other side of the city the
city
i still be i became aware that it
existed and so many people just need to
know that
they just need to know something exists
and need to have access
and so um once i began to see the world
differently and
and this goes back and it's the last
thing i'll say there's this quote
that i came across from einstein very
early on within
within those first couple of years that
the most fundamental decision that you
make
is whether you live in a friendly or
hostile universe
and all i felt prior to that was
hostility
i was looking for problems everywhere
and it helped me to survive
but it debilitated me and it definitely
inhibited me from being able to thrive
and so i just start to see good
everywhere i start to see the goodness
of people i start to see
you know the potential of my health and
my ability to serve
so yes that's a lot but you know that's
kind of what i went through
that was that was good i've got a couple
of comments um one
you talked about i think something
people really need to be aware of if
they're sick
is to get more opinions if you go to the
medical system and you're chronically
ill
every doctor you talk to from my
experience anyway every doctor says
this is the answer and they kind of they
don't tell you not to get more opinions
but they kind of infer that there's no
point because
the medical system is one that is not
true
especially if you need surgery go see
like four people especially if it's a
serious surgeon
i had my ankle re-replaced a couple of
years ago i got four opinions
and each one was so different it was
terrifying like one guy was like you
know we replaced the whole thing you're
screwed you're gonna end up with it
amputated when you're 40.
and he was one of the top guys in the
states and i went to switzerland and got
an opinion and he said
only one component needs to be changed
it's a fairly simple recovery it wasn't
but it's a fairly simple recovery
and you'll be good for the rest of your
life that was the guy and that was the
guy i went with
right so if you're looking for
physicians or health professionals
go to the person that says from my
experience go to the person who says we
can help
this isn't forever like you can get out
of this and a lot of that
a lot of that's from natural health
people but if you go to someone who says
this is a chronic disease you're going
to get worse and worse and worse you're
going to be stuck on medic medications
forever and then
you know you're on this till you die
that's probably not the person you want
treating you
that's that's my that's my point anyway
i gotta i gotta mention this because
one of the most important things and now
you know being at this level for
all these years i know the the guys you
know the top neuroscientists the top
cardiologist top gastroenterologist you
know these are my friends and colleagues
and i'll tell you this
if and i still see this and i
would think people get this by now
especially if they're in my sphere
but so often we don't realize that we
get to choose who we work with
right and you need to make it a mandate
to work with somebody who has the same
goal as you
if your goal is to not be diabetic
you need to be working with somebody who
believes you don't have to be
type 2 diabetic that this was elicited
there was an
onset something happened that changed
what your metabolism was doing
making you diabetic you weren't born
this way something happened
so what can we do to reverse engineer
the condition right
so you need to be working with somebody
who has the same goal as you
like if your goal is is a certain amount
of weight loss if your goal
is you know to to not be on medication
if the person you're working with if
they don't have the same goal as you and
they're telling you in fact the opposite
thing
get somebody else we have full
permission to do that but i think a
big reason we don't do that number one
is you know this nocebo effect and
there's kind of this fear elicited
and you know we have this trust
especially in authority figures that
they have the right answer
and it can drive right past our kind of
executive function in our brain our
reasoning our ability to distinguish
between right and wrong it kind of
bypasses that
and also i think today more than ever
it's also a
symptom of our busyness you know and
just feeling like i don't have time
you know this person's saying this i
don't want to have to do the work
to find somebody but these are the
biggest decisions like we spend more
time
looking for a vacation home than we do
for our health care
or we do for you know putting a plan
together for our health or putting a
plan together for our goals
if we would invest just as that as much
time as we do online shopping
you know and i'm not saying the online
shop but just like where are our
priorities because
the truth is solutions if your heart is
still beating
man like there's so many different
possibilities
that um you have to explore yes
completely agree you should just search
and search and search until you find the
answer
and not listen to the people who say the
answer is not out there
especially if you're chronically ill
okay
that was it oh one more comment on that
you mentioned a study with silica
oh this is a good one okay go ahead go
ahead
no no can you get into that because i've
heard bad things about silica being like
nano particles and damaging to the gut
potentially
yeah all right so one of the things that
got me into
really looking at bone density and
specific nutrients there was actually
this
study i came across on racehorses and
now this is a it's a very interesting
field
right so this is like a billion dollar
industry
you know a horse can be like generating
or worth like tens of millions of
dollars easily
so breaking a bone is like serious
business
so they want to find out how to increase
the bone density of these horses so
they had the control group who did
nothing then they had a study group of
horses where they gave them
supplements basically you know what we
deemed to be
essential nutrients vitamins minerals
but then they had another
which in the that group of horses did in
fact improve their bone density
but then there was another group of
horses that received the supplements and
they walked the horses
and they had an even radically higher
level of bone density
so number one that points to the
importance of movement for assimilation
of nutrients that's a big part of the
word what exercise is really meant to be
it's very close to the word xor
size which is kind of like to get stuff
out of you that shouldn't be there in a
sense
um but also it's about assimilation and
elimination right so those are the
things that exercise is really designed
to do
but with that in that category of
nutrients you know things like silica
i don't recommend just taking isolated
nutrients by the way
uh as far as the data unless of course
they're food based versions
but we just need to be very careful and
intentional about the supplements we're
taking
because the word supplement has become
skewed now it's just like
it's everything you know oh you don't
whatever just take a multi or whatever
but the word supplement means to
supplement something
right it shouldn't be the whole thing
and
so silica and food that's great like
one of the foods that i use early on
this is gonna it might sound a little
weird for some folks
but it was aloe right aloe vera and i
would like fillet off part of this like
gel
and like throw it into smoothies and
this whole thing and
man it was so rich in all of these
nutrients that were needed once i start
to research
and there's another really fundamental
question asking what is the organ made
of
right so if it's a heart issue asking
what what is my heart actually made of
and unfortunately
again knowing the award-winning top
cardiologists
out there they'll go to school for 12
years
and literally have no idea what the
heart is made of
do you underst like there's a
fundamental flaw of our entire system
your heart is made from food it's
literally made of the food that you eat
the blood running through your veins and
arteries is made from food
your arteries themselves it's made from
food
and yet they don't get any education on
what the organs are actually made of it
is it's criminal
really and this the point is look at the
results look at the results we've seen
in the field of medicine every year it
keeps getting worse
heart disease is it's unbelievable it's
unbelievable
and the best we can come up with again
is treating symptoms
right well here's some lacinopril here's
a statin
right and all of these things come with
side effects it's just treating the
symptom and it's not treating the
underlying cause
which the journal of the american
medical association did this big mad
analysis 2018
and affirmed poor diet is the number one
cause of our chronic diseases here in
this country
and it's as if it doesn't exist because
they get that same cookie cutter
answer which is you know make sure you
increase your you know whole grains
watch your fat you know make sure you
watch your fat and uh you need to
exercise
and also not understanding that our
medical professionals are absolutely
getting demolished themselves it's like
a
it's like a badge of honor to destroy
your health
going through medical school the most
sleep deprived the most
malnutritioned and i talked about this
in each smart as well because it needs a
light shine on it
you know and the incredibly high rates
of suicide and depression and the
skyrocketing rates of of heart disease
and cancer
far more than the general population is
what we see in our medical professionals
so we're being taught the word doctor
really you know derives from the word
meaning teacher
but that is it's left the equation and
the system has put
been become so oppressive to physicians
that they really operate in volume
and it's these five minute in and out
office visits they're not actually
looking at so if you're coming in and
you've
you know you've got high blood pressure
you've got hypertension they're not
asking about
you know how how's your work situation
happening or asking about your
relationship
yeah they're not asking about your sleep
quality none of these things especially
not
about your diet because they don't know
you know 99
of the time and it's not that they don't
want to it's just not part of the
education system
and if you take a very smart person and
you teach them the wrong thing
they become world-class at doing the
wrong thing right and that's really what
we're seeing right now
and i believe especially with what's
happening in the world right now we have
an opportunity to change it everything
is kind of so shaken up and
malleable it looks like a big tornado
[ __ ] storm
but this is when things can get changed
you know so i'm really excited about it
first i was kind of
you know i was very irritated early on
in this because
again the cdc came out uh in september
after compiling the data and i was
talking about this back in april looking
at the data from italy
94 of the people who lost their lives
in association with this virus had an
average of 2.6 pre-existing chronic
diseases
right it's unbelievable it's the it's
the number one risk factor
and it's not being talked about because
what the media does is it shifts right
well what about the six percent who are
perfectly healthy
are you kidding me and even that
definition of perfectly healthy
i can be as healthy as i want to be and
i can go and demolish myself going out
you know on it on a book tour
and going and doing media and all this
stuff and my immune system is going to
get compromised
and i can get sick enough to die from
something that i'm already carrying
because all of us carry trillions of
virus particles
every single day we have upwards of
about 400 trillion
viruses in it on our bodies right now
and many of them can make you sick
but it's when your immune system is
compromised but i didn't even know we
get
into that turn but you know oh my
goodness
when i um so i i had to see a
rheumatologist every six months
or every three months depending on how
bad the arthritis was and
i eliminated my arthritis with diet and
i went and i went off of all my
medications and i didn't tell my
rheumatologist because in canada
if you stop listening to your doctor
they can fire you i don't know if it's
the same in america but they can just
stop seeing you if you're not listening
to them and i didn't
want his view of my joints and knowing i
was coming off of medication to affect
how he saw me so i was like i just won't
this is like a
blind test i was like i just won't say
anything's changed and i'll see if he
thinks my arthritis is gone because i
think it is
so my arthritis went away and i
tentatively said also i'm
i'm not on any medications anymore and i
think it's caused i simplified it i was
like i think it's caused by sugar
which wasn't it's more complicated than
that but i was like i think it's caused
by sugar
and he just he couldn't it was like i'd
said something that he couldn't
understand he was like a 60 year old
dude one of the top rheumatologists in
toronto
he said something and it like glitched
him and then i
like kind of like looked at him i looked
at him and i was like this guy's sick
right he's overweight he's really
exhausted he's way overworked and his
fingers are swollen
i was like he has osteoarthritis right
so why am i and then i didn't see him
again after that because i was like why
am i going in to see
a dude who hasn't fixed his own
arthritis
right so yeah it's wild west out there
in the medical profession
yeah it makes it makes no sense you know
but this comes to
it's just a system of thinking that
we've been indoctrinated with
when we get here you know and once we
and this is why i'm so excited about
this and just to have these
conversations because today like there's
no
there's no gatekeeper and people getting
educated and just being able to just
be i'm a very logical analytical person
you know i'm a scientist i want to see
the data i'm very much a kind of
seeing as believing type of tendency but
there's so much that we don't know
as well and a big fundamental flaw of
this system
is and like you said this and i love
when you said this
every person you went to believed that
their way was the way this is the way
and it's just not true across the board
even with in my clinical practice when i
got really successful
with folks coming in with type 2
diabetes and they're on metformin
they're on insulin folks coming in with
their bag of medication who have
hypertension or
alzheimer's the list goes on and on i
got
really good when we start to see like 80
percent of folks
being able to you know manage their
blood sugar without medication working
alongside their physician
when we were able to see like over 80
percent of people a success rate
what changed was i finally started to
pay attention to them and what
they needed because prior to that which
i think we gotta go go through that
phase
whatever i was into that's what the
patients were gonna be doing
if i think raw food is the best metric
that's what you're gonna do if i think a
vegan diet is best that's what you're
going to do if i think keto's best
that's what you're going to do
and that's this that's the trap that we
can fall into
as nutritionists and health care
professionals
is thinking that your way is the only
way and that is sick it's so far from
the truth
and i know all the guys like i know the
top keto person the top vegan person the
top
um uh carnivore person the top
mediterranean diet person the list goes
on these are all my friends i love these
guys and
there's so much infighting right now and
and it's not amongst these guys it's
amongst the people who
subscribe to their diets because
oftentimes and
here's the thing i want people to know
is that they're not doing this to be
malicious
they're not coming out with a
controversial carnivore diet to be
malicious
they're doing it because they've seen
great success with their patients
they've helped people who
who weren't able to be helped doing
something else and we have to just honor
that it's tough when it doesn't fit into
our paradigm
right the same thing with a vegan diet
like same you know
people on this other camp over here can
think it's the most ridiculous thing
but people are getting results and lives
are being saved that's why it's promoted
but here's the issue it's not successful
for everybody as a matter of fact with
most of these diet frameworks
a massive percentage of people don't get
the results everybody else gets
and this is what i really brought
forward is
eat smarter is a unifier of all these
different diet frameworks
because nobody's excluded we're taking
the principles that makes every one of
them effective
with the hallmark being you have a
unique metabolic fingerprint
that's unlike anybody who's ever existed
in human history
your metabolism is like no one who will
ever exist in the future
and the craziest part is that your
metabolism right now
is going to be different from the person
a week from now
it's continuously changing and in flux
and it's fluid and if you don't
understand the tools to adapt as
as life goes on we're going to continue
to be imprisoned with the diet framework
which again it might give you some
results but then i've seen this many
times
somebody takes on a diet framework a
popular diet framework
they get great results for even a year
and then the weight starts coming back
or the arthritic symptoms start coming
back or maybe they start their their
weight is cool but now they start to
have like
symptoms of an autoimmune disease they
start to have thyroid issues whatever
the case might be
and they start to blame themselves like
i'm just not doing the diet hard enough
i just got a keto harder i just got a
vegan harder i just got to go harder in
it
and then my symptoms will go away when
these diet frameworks
might not allow for something that your
unique metabolism needs
or it might be telling you to do
something that is not in alignment with
what your unique metabolic fingerprint
is
you know so i want us to be educated on
just kind of the
the essentials of understanding our own
metabolism so this is the first time in
book form
which is crazy that i'm saying this this
is nuts that it's at this point where
it's 20 21.
um but i'm taking people behind the
scenes
and actually showing them how their
metabolism works
let's like how does fat loss work
how does it work what is where does fat
go where does it go when you quote burn
it where does it does it go to
the multiverse like how does the process
work so like demystifying it so that we
feel more empowered
you know and that's what it's really
about and then from there also
what are the key nutrients that drive
this process over here
which nutrient is required for cck
and leptin and ghrelin to do their jobs
properly like
we have data on all these things you
know and there's a plethora of sources
to get these things from and that's
what's beautiful as well
is that it doesn't have to be this one
thing if i don't have this one food
that everybody says that i should eat or
like then i'm not gonna get the results
everybody else is getting that's what's
so wonderful about
nutrition and nature and food there's so
much variety
so many options and so many paths to the
goal
i usually tell people because people do
if they
if they get a whole bunch of healing
with one diet they'll stick to it
even if the diet stops working and you
have to keep your mind
open because your body does crazy things
so so sometimes you've managed to hit
you know
some nail on the head for your health
but then something else pops up and so
you have to keep
an open mind no matter what because i
know i had a massive
mindset transformation twice right i
went super low carb
and i my arthritis went away and all my
autoimmune
symptoms went away and i was like holy
[ __ ] low carb
low carb is the thing and then and i was
very low carb and then low carbs stopped
working and and i was just like how
is this possible given the fact it
worked for a year and now i have
arthritis skin and i'm eating the same
foods
how is that possible and then i did
another switch i went to carnivore
and that helped right but
still michael why did i have that first
initial period where i could eat more
foods without arthritis
like something changed and that went
away
so yeah i do recommend like do a whole
bunch of research
try and try to listen to a lot of
different views
like don't just listen to one view find
something that works like that's cool
but
listen to everybody and try and keep the
open mind you had at the beginning when
you switched into the first diet you're
doing or you might be missing something
and bite
and life might come back to bite you a
little bit later
yeah that's such a great point and i
would say also i would encourage
people to listen to people who are
also aware that their way isn't the only
way
i think that that's very healthy right
now and again many of
the the very very best people are
really taking on that perspective
thankfully unfortunately i learned this
you know 10 15 years ago
but right now again like you mentioned
having this belief that your way is the
only way can
just be can be dangerous it can be
dangerous especially as a healthcare
professional
so just pay attention to that you know
because there's a lot of options and as
you mentioned
as we move and evolve things are going
to change and
once we can get the tools that we can
continuously adapt as things change
and by the way one of those things i got
to share this really quickly
because it also ties into what we talked
about earlier is this epicalor
controller
one of the most fundamental parts of our
unique metabolism has to do with our
microbiome
and people have heard this term so much
it's just the microbiome microbiome
it's like tossed around but it's not
it's it has not been really justified in
relationship to something
visceral something that we can really
attach to and understand
it seems very mystical right we know
that the majority of our immune system
is located in our gut we've got
potentially two pounds of microbes in
our gut
and just again trillions
of what makes up our microbiome and
we've got a mic
microbiome all the fungi we carry we've
got the
virum all the viruses we care we have
archaea
we've got all of these different
microbes that make us up and 99
at least of our genes that we're
carrying around are not our own genes
they're the genes of microbes right if
we go gene for gene
now of course they're very small but
these
the genetic output of these microbes
affects us and our unique metabolism so
what i wanted to do was
let's tie this microbiome truth to
something visceral for people and what
that really is today whether we want to
acknowledge it or not most people
care about nutrition because they want
to look good that's really the big
driving force
and so your microbiome makeup is one of
the
most powerful epic caloric controllers
determining
your body fat composition so what does
this look like
this was and i break this down more in
each smart i'll just give a brief
summation but
this was published in the journal cell
and researchers discovered that there's
a certain
bacteria strain in mice that actually
blocked their intestines from absorbing
as many calories from their food
all right it literally just blocked and
so that would be worth a lot of money
here's the thing this is the allopathic
thinking let's p
let's put that in a bottle let's put in
a bottle of whatever bacteria strain
that is and sell it so we can block
people's intestines from absorbing as
many calories for the food
eat whatever you want take this pill
here's the this is but this is the
problem
there are going to be side effects and
it can be
treacherous they can be devastating
because when we're talking about the
microbiome and manipulation
you might be preventing your microbiome
like that relationship by blocking
something
from producing short chain fatty acids
right these scaffolds
that protect the lining of a
gastrointestinal tract and also scaffold
is important for cognitive function your
brain and gut
are hyper connected the list goes on and
on
something is going to get torn up and
screwed up and just again look at our
history we keep doing this
now let's couple that then plus some
folks are like we're not mice
let's couple this with human studies and
so this was conducted by researchers at
the weisman institute
and this is what i would see also my
clinical practice
they affirmed that there's a certain
bacteria cascade
that is most notably causative of
obesity
all right so here in my clinical
practice i could have somebody that i've
never met never seen a picture of
before they come in have them send out
to get a stool sample done
right they're sending the kit they poop
in the little like nacho basket
send it in and then i get the report
back it's forever ruined
so everyone listens i did that on
purpose
yeah i did that all burgers sneaky
so i get the report back and i can look
at their
their makeup of their microbes and i can
i can know
with extreme accuracy whether or not
they're obese without ever seeing them
based
on their microbes and so these
researchers at the weizmann institute
know this
and what they did was they took
bacterial samples
fecal samples from folks who had the
bacteria cascade associated with obesity
and they implanted that into lean mice
then they took
samples from what was called helene
bacteria so humans who had a fecal
content or bacteria cascade associated
with leanness
and they implanted that into lean mice
those mice stay the same
even though they're in the same diet
they stay the same but the mice who
received the fecal transplant
of the quote fat bacteria these mice
became insulin resistant
they gained weight and gained body fat
even though they're eating the same diet
just changing the microbes changed their
metabolism
significantly and the last little point
i'll share and this is from researchers
at st louis university and this is just
my hometown so
they they have this incredible database
of identical twins
and you don't get any more identical
than identical twins as far as like what
can happen with different people
all right so we've got identical twins
but the prerequisite was finding
a set of identical twins where one of
the twins has a microbiome
cascade associated with obesity while
the other one doesn't
and track them over years and see what
happens and sure enough
the twin who had the microbiome
associated with insulin resistance and
obesity
had a far greater incidence of becoming
obese
than their twin even though they're
eating the same diet from the same house
the same household the same environment
every time does that even happen
your microbes are hyper intelligent
they're really the first determining
factor
on whether or not you're going to absorb
energy from your food
and researchers at yale university
school of medicine just to kind of
pinpoint this we have the you know this
kind of
gut brain axis and your brain
and your gut your brain can literally
tell your gut the hypothalamus
specifically
can tell your gut can communicate with
your microbes
and tell your gut to increase the
absorption of calories from the food
that you're eating
or it can tell your gut to suppress and
reduce the amount of
calories and nutrients you're absorbing
from your food based on your brain
and your gut's assessment of what you
have stored
and you would think if you've got a lot
stockpiled your brain would tell your
gut i've had i've got enough
but this is where we get into one of the
biggest epidemics today
that's not being talked about of neural
inflammation
it's one of the biggest issues so i've
mentioned researchers at yale university
school of medicine
specifically hypothalamic inflammation
this can
this can change your rate of calorie
burn by
hundreds if not even over a thousand
calories a day
easily eating the same diet eating the
exact same diet it can suppress and
reduce
your metabolic rate just by your brain
and this gut communication so
inflammation in the gut and or in the
brain
can create this kind of what i call
hormonal clogs
where there's this confusion where your
body has a lot of
stuff already stored especially if
you're in and this oh this is the last
point this is the point that'll bring it
all together
they affirm that hypothalamic
inflammation
is one of the biggest drivers of obesity
all right number one
but obesity is one of the biggest
drivers of hypothalamic and neural
inflammation so inflammation in the
brain
and if you don't think it's a big issue
we have over 200 million citizens here
in the united states right now who are
overweight or obese
we have 43 of folks here in the united
states are clinically obese
and within the next few years here we're
going to hit 50 percent
of the population if we don't do
something this issue is chronic
some of these incredible diet frameworks
accidentally address
this neural inflammation and help the
metabolism to heal
but i promise you're not going to buy a
book out there or get a program that's
talking about like let's get make sure
your brain is healthy so that your
your gut and your bacteria can actually
have some intelligence in the in the
rate of caloric absorption
and i want to throw out one little tip
for everybody and this isn't an
advocation for this it's just the data
exists on and i think is is
absolutely mind-blowing so researchers
at auburn university so if you're like
how can i reduce
neural inflammation also how do i know
if my brain's inflamed
you're not gonna know until it's too
late because the brain itself doesn't
have any pain receptors
your brain could tell tell you that your
elbow hurts that your elbow's inflamed
but it can't tell you that it's inflamed
all right which is
this cosmic joke it's like a cosmic yeah
that's [ __ ] up that's not funny
so these researchers at auburn
university discovered that
oleo kanthal rich extra virgin olive oil
is remarkably effective at reducing
neural inflammation
number one and this is what really trips
me out
it was found to be able to help repair
the blood-brain barrier
which gets damaged from inflammation
from toxin exposure
just from our day-to-day lives which
damage the blood-brain barrier which is
kind of like an internal security system
your brain only allows in very specific
things and we call it neural nutrition
and once that internal security system
gets damaged things start getting into
your brain that should not be there
creating more inflammation and olive oil
was found to
fix this i again like
it wasn't like i was a big fan of olive
oil it's just the data is there and it's
been used for thousands of years
and so what the research found was two
to three tablespoons a day
but within that though there's a whole
conversation of nuance of like
where what type of olive oil how's it
stored how am i using it all those
pieces and you know we talk about all
that in each smarter two
make sure it's not rancid soybean oil oh
my gosh
don't even get me started who is that a
day that don't even get me started
listen
you got me started listen we
we just looked at and i was working with
uh dr kate shanahan
and she's just incredible she worked
with the um the los angeles lakers for
quite some time
um but what what what we did was we
looked at the data
from biopsies from folks in the earlier
part of like the 1900s
to today and back in the early part of
the 1900s
human biopsy so from our fat content
so what is our fat cell actually storing
it was about two to four percent
pufas right polyunsaturated fatty acids
in human fat tissue
today it's about 25
polyunsaturated fats in the average
person in their fat tissue itself
the very ingredients that make up human
fat has
changed dramatically we're like the
ingredients to make up a person is so
different
and the problem is these piling
saturated fats just
in nature is not a bad thing if they're
coming from real whole foods
but the reason that it's such a high
content specifically stored in our fat
cells
is because of these highly refined toxic
oils which one of the studies that i
cover in each martin this was published
in one of the most prestigious journals
in
inhalation toxicology found that even
smelling those [ __ ] oils can damage
your
dna just inhaling the smell and now
these these kind of things should be
alarming for us but we've been consuming
it even if you go to whole foods
i'm very alarmed yeah it's crazy like if
people knew the processing that has to
go into
taking you know soy soy beans or
corn or canola and turning it into
something palatable by humans
all of the the bleaching and deodorizing
and
high uh chemical processing all the
different chemicals added to it
it is disgusting it's terrible and even
at whole foods in the hot bar
they're using canola oil still because
of the marketing like this is a
healthier oil
it's called vegetable oil it's not kale
oil
it's just marketing like this is it's
absolute trash
you know and humans have never consumed
this stuff except in real whole foods
but we have been consuming olive oil
cold pressed olive oil
for thousands of years that's the
difference
okay sean i'm gonna have to let you go
we didn't even get that was fascinating
i was gonna bring up some i wanted to
delve into your business a little bit i
didn't even get into that so
that was that was great thank you very
much where can people
find you online thank you yeah this has
been fun
uh folks can can find me at the model
health show dot com just wherever
they're listening to this
awesome show they can find my show it's
called the model health show
and you can find each smarter wherever
books are sold i'm very grateful
uh when the book came out i didn't share
this with you it became
the number one bestseller of all books
in the u.s
uh the first a couple of days but the
thank you and this was again
it's on the list with like obama and
like matthew mcconaughey
and this is a book about food and so for
me it's very
inspiring that you know right now
despite the appearances people care
about this stuff
and it's just a thing of accessibility
in education and making learning fun
you know so i'm very inspired right now
just to get our communities healthier
uh so yeah you can pick it up anywhere
books are sold amazon barnes and noble
all that good stuff the side effect
though that i didn't share was that
because of that it the book sold out and
everybody's
blaming covid related delays and all
this stuff with books coming back
so they're back in stock now and you can
find them again everywhere books are
sold and also
the audiobook is available uh became a
number one bestseller as well it's
really
really really cool to just be able to
pop that on and listen to uh so and you
can find the anything about the book as
well at each smarterbook.com
okay that'll be linked below thank you
very much for coming on
perfect thank you so much for having me
[Music]
you